one one last question you said you you
you got into writing about D transition
because you're interested in heretics
and now you've kind of become a heretic
I think you manifested that is that did
you want to always kind of live on the
outside of mainstream so I mean I kind
of do which is why I'm a comedian right
like my job I guess other than
prostitution is like the second oldest
job like I'm like the town crier I'm the
fool I'm the whatever like I'm the guy
that's in the public square just
shouting and then people come by and
throw them change whatever but what
about heretics so fascinated you and and
you seem very comfortable being one I
guess that's probably because I haven't
left my house in three months and so I'm
like I no longer have people screaming
at me yeah I mean element of
self-reflection there I don't think it
was conscious at the time but I would
say that the writing that I've done
before and you know and after that piece
tends to I I try to find the unexpected
and things you know and I've learned
that almost nothing nothing you see is
as it appears to be and so I think
that's in part why I'm drawn to these
things and then the more I read the more
I realized that everything I think I
know about the world is uh is more
complex than I thought so
yes more and more informed you get the
less you know you feel like you have any
clue of what's going on and the less you
realize you can trust institutions and I
don't want to be like you know I'm not
Donald Trump I don't unfortunately I
don't have his his money or his tan
spray tan
but you know I don't believe in like the
I don't want to be like the fake news
person or whatever but I will say like a
lot of mainstream and I saw the current
media it's the carving team thing happen
was completely fake jussie Smollett I
mean there's a lot we've seen a lot okay
I got a question for you yeah yeah how
how long did it take for you to think
like Oh Jesse smells [ __ ] well you
know what bothered me about the Jesse
smollett saying and this is what always
bothers me and and I I've I spent my
life in New York City LA finished cago a
bunch I have witnessed very few
ooh things that I would consider you
know and I've been in places where
everybody's drunk I spent a lot of time
with drunks in comedy clubs and things
like that people have yelled things out
at me I mean it's part of the [ __ ]
contract you sign up for when you're a
comedian I've been on subways late at
night and all that stuff the idea that
there were these Trump supporting gang
of people in a metropolitan city
committing hate crime seemed very weird
to me impossible no but it seemed odd to
me that that whenever when I heard that
it made me go huh
really and 2:00 a.m. there's just guys
with Trump hats on going after Jesse
smollett who's getting a Subway sandwich
at 2:00 a.m. yeah that was the thing
that got me I was like are you rich why
are you eating Subway why aren't you
make animating or GrubHub and something
wiring freezing you and I and I and I
did a video about this several weeks
later I was always attacked by elizabeth
warren supporters i was hit with
feathers in a headdress and i was
attacked and so i understand what it's
like but did you did they come back and
apologize to you i'm sure that they did
weird thing about me is this again i
came out late in life i came out of 25
then i started stand-up comedy right
away i quit drinking the same year so
you had all of these things happen to
once i became essentially another person
right i never had the time to like just
be gay for two years and like just party
and drug it up and [ __ ] i came out i had
to stop doing drugs and drinking and i
started doing comedy so it was this
weird Prabhas an actor as a little kid
like i have a lot of traditionally gay
experiences right I'm insanely talented
and gorgeous so when you have I do I and
you know what I look like how they do
when they don't do as well because they
seen older ballerinas so the reality is
you're wrong and right at the same time
but I always you know here's the thing
man I hate groupthink
I've always hated it's so weird to make
it's the antithesis of humor like this
this weird kind of cultish I you know I
was a drug addict I understand what it's
like to live this binary existence of
like I'm either high or I'm sober I'm
getting drugs I'm not getting drugs and
so to me when I got rid of drugs and I
stopped drinking and I went into comedy
and I was doing this and I was following
the path that I should be following like
I just I I really started to get weird
about people that had you know no room
for nuance cuz I'm like that's where
everything lives everything lives in
nuanced jokes live in nua and i've
always a fan of like you know you know
people people say i don't present as gay
so it's easier for me 100% true they're
100% right about that
but like being gay is the tenth most
[ __ ] up thing about me right in terms
of the life I've lived I mean I bought a
house when I was 22 with the subprime
mortgage on cocaine I mean uh you know
most people wake up you know gay people
will wake up or straight people wake up
next to someone and go how did I get
here I woke up in a $700,000 home and
said how did I get here and there was
yeah and I owned the property so I had
done all this weird [ __ ] I mean I
dropped acid on the 8th grade stage of
my graduation oh you know I was doing
acid when I was in eighth grade I was
doing cocaine in eighth grade in ninth
grade I was hanging out at crack houses
I was like doing wild stuff and then I
was selling subprime mortgages for a
long time trying to help the country
really and and and I was just involved
in all this weird [ __ ] man and to me
sexuality is a part of the story but
it's not the whole story for most people
it is their whole story most gay people
for most people it is there's something
wrong with that because it's like you're
completely right I mean yeah I find it
like very I find it aggravating and I
don't find it I don't find it
interesting at all but you know and like
I lived like mostly in Queens sort of
queer circles for most of my life and so
I basically got excommunicated in the
last few years and when I think back
about that time it's like all we talked
about was being gay that's all we talked
about right
somebody'd be like paper or plastic and
I'd be like I'm gay it's boring now I
know that's everywhere yes everybody
every everyone's gay now and it's weird
it's so I always felt like yeah I'm sure
I had internalized homophobia this and
the other thing but then like there was
a time of comedy when I started to a
comedy when I said I was gay on stage
people say ooh or like people would be
like openly hostile to it but then it
turned to where like I even like it when
in longer sets I say it in short sets I
stop saying it because when I said it
people would clap and that's the worst
thing in comedy few big good for you and
the way Oh enough what a weird [ __ ]
thing
what but people are heavily invested in
that which makes them unique and it
makes you unique is your sexuality and
otherwise you're a basic [ __ ] person if
what makes you unique is you sick which
is what I love about all these people
they're like I'm queer and I love the
Real Housewives and I love you know
frappuccino and I'm like you're just a
basic [ __ ] right it doesn't matter who
you sleep with you like you you have
nothing unique about you groups of
queers are conformist like every other
group I mean we break up into these
tribes it's not that different from high
school and they're all like each other
and you know I'm that's I guess an
offensive thing to say but it comes like
Long's observations with hanging out
with these communities yeah I mean how
does it affect you like are you when you
say you're actually Munich eh do you
just not get the invites anymore what no
yeah I don't I like basically live a
pretty friendless existence and I do
have I have like three or four friends I
mean most of them are older I have
friends in like their 60s and 70s now
like just some old Mountain lesbian you
talk to who's on a houseboat and she
chain smokes inside is what you want
that you don't want a lot of friends you
want to change Seattle in the [ __ ]
70s to learn how to be a pilot I mean
she's just fascinating or I could hang
out with career people who only talked
about being queer right
so yeah I would say I don't know I don't
have very many friends but I do have a
wife and a dog so I'm still okay